[Music]
okay dude what is your perfect day
uh
in in my existence now or just in a uh
if I could craft a perfect existence
I guess
I guess uh no no okay let's do it like
this you cleared your calendar tomorrow
and you said you know I have an
unlimited budget tomorrow within your
memes within your means to have the
perfect day what would it look like
honestly yeah it's gonna sound so like
Normie Facebook person okay I just
spending time with my dog yeah no I
would
I'd want to get up it
like six
get some friends together
go to the track
um we all Drive shitty rental carts so
there's no qualms about
um
crashing or ruining the carts there are
pieces of [__] cover a little group
lunch somewhere where what kind of food
what are you thinking Korean favorite
place Korean barbecue okay yep for lunch
after a day racing you're hungry right
okay just just pile Drive in I mean you
can kind of kiss the rest of your day
goodbye though after that nah no no okay
then retire with them then retire with
the film shower the movie okay you know
yeah
what movie
Too Fast Too Furious just a car day it's
a [__] good movie Just A Car day yeah
Gone in 60 Seconds yeah why not
something like that
yeah I don't know I'm aiming low here
but some yeah something like that yeah
you know or you know
could just
get up at seven
work out with my lady yeah make some
breakfast yeah go to the beach yeah sit
with a dog somewhere yeah
come back have some dinner yeah
Watch Too Fast Too Furious yeah the
simple things it's funny how you start
wanting less
yeah I feel like when you're 20 it's
like oh well I got a [__] Bali yeah
for sure I go to Bali and go I'll get a
table at a club yeah uh meet up with a
model yeah
yeah what was your perfect Davey
uh I think it would have to be in
October or November right fall offshore
winds have started you wake up in the
morning
you wake up you know whatever six you
know sun's not quite up yet you go
surface pumping get out there with some
friends surf for a couple hours and then
it would be like
Diner it's right to a diner right that's
probably my favorite like genre of food
ever it's just like this thing Diner
like bacon and eggs like Mel's driving
or something like that there's a place
in Manhattan Beach that's really good
Local Yolk I believe it's called
I just [__] up some diner food right and
some diner coffee okay and then
and then I would go and then I would go
lay probably with the cats on the dog
and Kelsey
like you know post post morning surf
post breakfast yeah take a little nap
okay maybe like another afternoon like
activity of some sort running or
volleyball Dang or something like that
double up
I think you'd have to like an activity
yeah an activity something a little
maybe a little competitive something fun
yeah with that and then yeah big group
dinner somewhere
and then yeah just pack it in early
yeah
yeah I like that yeah I feel relaxed
yeah listening to that everyone's like
you [__] are all dude I wake up
at 12 get my dick sucked go pound
[__] two two rails and just go in
dude yeah I feel like when you're yeah
when you're younger it's like I want to
meet people that was my perfect day new
connecting house like I know who I like
yeah I don't want to meet anybody I know
exactly what I want to spend time with I
know what I want to do yep I'm gonna do
those things yeah the wife might be
listening to this my perfect day would
be waking up in Italy again and
getting married all over oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and my perfect day would be
right now when I'm getting married yeah
yeah
I do actually though I do
completely I said this before but I mean
you're gonna feel it too
that that phrase when people were like
oh man my wedding day is like the
greatest day of my life yeah yeah that
get that gets like clowned so hard
and I just you know I just gotta just
gotta make a stand for all the husbands
out there you know I want these [__]
weirdos who have never had like good
strong relationships on like
[__] podcasts and [__] villainize the
idea of choosing a partner yeah there's
something uh that can be very cool and
special about that yeah of course you
know you know also I feel like there's
something special about your wedding day
where it's like
you like I know it's gonna sound shitty
but it's like all about you guys and
your love and also like the family and
the friends and everything and everyone
that's like played a part and yeah
I feel like that's gonna be that's gonna
feel really special too yeah I mean even
the weddings like you know the I don't
know one of my best best friends
weddings was in January and just like I
cried every single one because it's just
like God [__] damn it this energy is
amazing yeah yeah dude
okay
what's the craziest thing your dog has
eaten
semen
a bullet
[Music]
there we go that's a good callback got a
gunpowder
556 shells
no um craziest thing I think Chili's
would be that edible right
uh I gave him like cereal diarrhea yeah
for sure but I mean that was also like
he was a puppy so I don't even know if
he really ate anything I think he just
got diarrhea and we were just paranoid I
feel like neither he was at a bar he
definitely ate something I feel like
neither of us have a good story like
that you know like I feel like that is a
question for people who have dogs where
it's like oh yeah he um ate part of a
barbed wire and we had to like go yeah
yeah like bigger dogs yeah just [__]
around yeah I mean for me it's it's
chili drinking the entire Taco birya
broth you ever been to Teddy's red tacos
in Venice no but you had Buria before
right you know it's just like entirely
just oil and just like thick flavor and
seasoning and spice and oil right yeah
we came downstairs and chili had us
my mouth in the thing and we were like
oh it was like it was like a pint
basically
and I'm like or more than a pint
probably like that big right and I'm
like oh no he drank some and I look and
it's completely gone I had a heart
attack
he's [__] water yeah for like two days
yeah yeah we had to take him to the vet
and get his whole [__] it was brutal
Ollie's never eaten anything crazy like
that the only thing he does do is
he likes to sit on top of blankets and
then clean his paws so my
by way of that he's always eating like
felt yeah and then you go
no but then he's always walking around
the house going like
like a cat that just hacking [__] up I'm
like dude because you keep [__] stop
doing that
that's the only thing funnier to me than
a human getting gross out and gagging is
when dogs do that [__] where they go
[Laughter]
all he'll just sit there and just
looking just kind of somber and then out
of nowhere he'll just
[Music]
I'm like bro oh my gosh all right
every time dude